it's looking very different look at this
place it's like a different man oh my
goodness it's good to see ya oh my gosh
I know what's happened that big massive
thing has been cut now oh man doesn't it
look bigger Wow oh it's looking good
oh my how much better does it look it
does
back in it doesn't it looks big doesn't
it it does not be bright looks so much
more spacious and hairy a lot grander
this is how it used to be back in the
day when you arrived you could just see
the castle I know now you can't see it
because of all the scaffolding properly
but all the trees have been taken down
now
the roof had fallen in because all the
trees all the moisture off the trees
were going into the into the castle
it was then causing it to be damp so
really they needed to go but getting all
the planning and to get rid of a lot of
the trees has been really difficult
building from scratch is a lot faster
and quicker than restoring a grade-two
star listed building great T star list
if it's like one down from a palace so
restoring the amount of people that you
need to get permission to do anything it
takes a lot of time but now we've had
all the planning approved of everything
we've had the a chartered surveyor as
well give it evaluation on the N value
which is looking very very promising so
I'm looking forward now to go around and
just seeing what's happening and what
they've done on the outside of the
building I can see the take looks like
they've taken the roof completely off
here which is good so I'm really excited
to see the project manager and get an
idea of exactly what's going on
sometimes hot that time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
know what close mine yellow oh yeah but
still trying to get the outside done by
Christmas the demo'd area is now fully
down and needs a lot more to be done to
be fair to make you safe but we'll have
a look at that minute now got a
maternity roost with bats we can't have
stars and so we've done another third
survey so we'll do that that's plan for
about weeks time next it's 14 days
between surveys then we get the license
then we can start dealing with the roof
areas and start taking the roof off and
have a an ecologist here to deal with
the bats as if we farm off Rhonda round
we'll have a look at the demo Darren
because your rental app you been able to
get in there last time okay
[Music]
we could have maximized the apartments
more and split them off into more
apartments but we've actually decided to
keep them bigger yeah rather than having
like 20 apartments or little one bed
Studios if we've got 10 or 12 really big
noise luxury high-end
yeah the high ceilings a fantastic they
look great when they're done it's just
getting heating right
get that right no problem at all yeah
these cameras have stops a number of
break-in attacks
yeah good the worst was quite a few
weeks ago now but four or five men
turned up at 1:15 in the morning and
simply set the cameras off at the back
what's going on with the castle well
Trevor's trying to get me to change the
name of it from Ridgewood house to
samuel leeds castle i suggested that it
might upset the neighbors so I think
I'll just leave it as a ribbed furred
house our plan is by the springtime in
2020 to have at least one like show home
is that realistic yeah where we can say
look this is this is this is this is the
finished result so not let's not just
like everything it's all going to be
ready but that all the outbuildings will
be ready we'll have one apartment at
least which is completely ready and
we've got some crazy exciting ideas
Trevor is come on board to help out with
the you know the vision of what we're
doing because Trevor's a man that knows
how to make money when it comes to
poverty in construction so happy days
and whenever I come here it's always
sunny so what can I say so there we are
that's how a July update of the castle
will you reckon the trouble listen it's
a fantastic building it needs an awful
lot of work is you know it is it is look
the whole roof it's gotta be taken off
laughs these pigs and then painstakingly
put back on and it's gonna be done in
stages to stop the bats from coming back
in because that the mini got bats
there's a license coming to get them
removed legally and then you've got to
make sure he don't let them back in so
you can't say I'm not a man revision
no no no no huge vision huge mission the
crazy thing is forty-five hundred grand
yeah spending about two million on it
yeah and value we've already had
Chartered Surveyors and valuers saying
it's gonna be at least 6 million 6
million look I think in conservative
6-minute I think over the top because as
you'd see there's other buildings
outside you can add value there out the
back and you've got a lot of land there
without buildings so there's other
things you can do as well so I think
you're gonna have far exceed the -
that's exciting
Trevor saying that Trevor saying that
means a lot because Trevor's very
experienced in property so the fact that
I'll be able to restore a castle that
was in ruins have the satisfaction of
doing that and become a millionaire and
then become a millionaire again and then
potentially more times it's just really
exciting
I personally don't have the time to be
here every day overseeing overseeing
what's going on that's why I've got
Adrian and I'm trying to persuade Trevor
we're trying to negotiate something
because to be honest I've got a lot of
holidays coming up I've got a lot of a
lot to kids need some help you need some
help I could do have a bit of hands-on
help so it's great some people like you
so I know we're trying to negotiate
something when you buy a grade 2 listed
building although you owned the freehold
the nation is entrusting this piece of
history to you yeah not just to update
it to the proper standard but to
maintain it look after it so I think
that's a huge responsibility I can see
that you're doing everything to the book
because if you don't it is a criminal
offence you go to prison if you don't do
this properly so you're not taking any
shortcuts here and I think that's
admirable and I think it adds huge value
to a piece of history that you're going
to make a mark in history to serve the
nation are you impressed with what we've
done so far yes I wonder if I
underground yes look it's only got a man
revision a lot of words are we done
there is there's a lot already done but
to go in and see everything you know is
going to be
a job and as the guys already said in
there that every time you open something
or pull something apart there's another
problem you don't thing I love about
this is after after restoring a castle
any other pool we're buying someone now
we're going to Lincoln we're building
six houses from scratch yeah if you just
said to me three years ago you're gonna
build six houses from scratch it would
have felt like a big deal
yeah after doing this everything seems
small can I tell you the six hours is
easy because unless you're stretching
yourself when you stretch yourself
you're growing and then when you're
looking at other projects everything
seems small so now I'm never gonna make
a lot of money on this but the person
who I'm gonna become as a result of
doing that is gonna be he's gonna be
Maggie and hopefully on the next update
video you'll be involved hey dragon
mother anyway I hope you found that
useful if you want more updates on the
castle or if you just want to see me out
other projects please do subscribe drop
a comment below don't forget to smash
that like button I'll see you guys next
time
[Music]